okay let me try and focus
London opening
one in from Poland
I had the this queen B6 line earlier
okay here we have this Knight D5 line
and there's some um like C4
oh this is interesting so I don't have
Bishop
huh
and now I'm trying to
remember if I've even studied this
position
C4 is a move
take take
probably just B3
yeah I'm getting hit with some annoying
prep
but actually interesting way of playing
against London
Bishop C4
so there is Bishop B4 here
the idea would be to play King F1
I guess I allow Knight C3
there's actually a line where I sacked
Exchange
maybe it's playable
yeah like take on E5 I take the bishop
or
or Pawn
it's like with Pawn
I'll have to check this line after the
game
it looks very playable for whites like
even though I'm technically down
material
it'll be Bishop for or bishop and Ponder
Rook
uh it's hard for black to actually move
the d-pawn
which means it's hard to complete the
queen side development
and there will be some attacking ideas
um
okay
thinking each five
I mean I just want to checkmate
it's nice the F7 Pawn is pinned so
there's no F6
so if I get in each six it's not easy to
deal with
I was thinking about thinking F6 and
media or H6 immediately
maybe I should have
ah
okay if I take
and there's King G2
hmm
foreign
[Music]
I want to advance the C Prime also
preventing their fire
India F4
yeah this should be straightforward now
but I can't get complacent
and just be aware of lack's ideas
okay this Pawn's now undefended
yeah the bishop was pinned so this was a
threat
going after G7 now and these moves
aren't possible
I'm not sure how that defends
oh
wasn't expecting that on percentage
oh I was so kind for my opponent to play
it out and let me do that
wow unexpected soundtrack mate
let's go
it's been a while since that's happened
it's a belated Christmas miracle